[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are exploring multiple
questions because we're doing an AMA
which means ask me anything ask us and
may a UAE ask us anything Oh wah wah wah
oh well is that when a cartoon sees
something that they like oh yeah oh yeah
it's like but it's a it's a horn of some
sort Thank You mythical beast - it's a
horn they replied to our request for
questions we log questions we like and
if we don't get to all of them then
we'll get to them later as long as we
occasionally get to your core know what
we do with the questions that we don't
like we print them out on poster boards
and we put lighter fluid on them and we
burn them individually right it's really
what we do when we're not doing what you
see us doing on camera is we are I mean
we are burning so much now it's so
wasteful it's why we smell like soot but
we call it the cleansing ceremony that's
what we call it yeah so if you are you
ready for another Clin if you submit bad
questions just know that you're fueling
the giant bonfire of poster board that
we have constantly going in the back
parking lot let's let's just get into
some questions oh but oh we got this new
idea we have a new lie to incentivize
you to maybe oh hang around and and
listen to this whole you're biscuit at
the end we're gonna start giving a
little Rex a little recommendation of
something that we are into so we're
gonna try that wrapping up every episode
with a little recommendation something
that you can experience in some way that
we've experienced and we really like
just a little Rick I know it could be
something in the world of entertainment
audio or visual it could be a product it
could be anything it could be a service
it could be anything it could be um it
could be an idea hey try on this idea
this week
just a little recommendation at the end
that if nothing from answering these
questions had a good takeaway from you
then we'll give you something okay if
you need to have a pride you know I like
it sometimes when I invest time in
something even like a podcast I like
having a takeaway knowing that there's
value in it knowing that there's value
in it and that's maybe a flaw in my
thinking that things just can't be
definitely is that they have to be hey
stay out of it it's one thing for me to
be introspective is another thing for
you to what's it what what it was it
calling extra extra special B X is when
you put your introspection on another
person don't insert respecting yourself
and you might not you know in certain
anything you are inserting oh I'm not
inserting pull out man
okay let's just get into here's a weird
wouldn't right off the bat from V at a
mythical V this is posted four hours ago
no that's just when we printed it said
4h Messiah oh maybe she's in the 4-h if
you were to have a third hand where
would you want it to be located and what
would you use it for hashtag ear
biscuits let me just start by saying
that I definitely know my first answer
to this and but we're not gonna talk
about that weird is good why is it we're
gonna just move on to the second I don't
know where the second third hand would
be the fourth hand well I'm sorry but I
just have to I have to go to the witch I
think he's your first answer because I I
thought that this is a naughty thing to
well it seemed like a naughty question
well no it doesn't no I think what you
mean is that we haven't all the answers
and I already said that I was back now
I'm not talking about that third hand
I'm talking about the fourth hand okay
let's not talk about the where it should
go let's talk about the other one but
once I started to think about the thing
you don't want to talk about I actually
didn't know what that meant so I kind of
do need you to tell me about it do you I
think we I can explain that to you later
it has to do is insert insert respect
whatever
the word is oh gosh you you came up with
it I'm not as naughty as you are in the
brain that's a fact jack that's
definitely true but I'd said I don't
want to talking about that so we're my
fourth hand would go is I would have I
find myself II hog in the hands I would
have a man can't hog hands you do the
same thing
we both do it because of the nature of
our haircuts we're not touching our hair
a lot I think I would have a hand
somewhere strategically placed
potentially inside the hair itself so
that could go away so it would be like
you know those things that you see those
commercials for the things that the
ladies can anybody could do it but it's
usually the ladies put those things in
their hair that gives it some volume
like a yeah so what is it called like
the bump or something like that it's got
like a yeah and like that I would have a
hand that was concealed inside the hair
and the hand itself could style and add
volume but then the hand could also just
reach and grab and straighten right
straighten the hair that's not a bad
idea but if you go bald then you just
look like a rooster you've got like a
it's like a [ __ ] comb I think at that
point you get it amputated you get an
amputated I know I know actually at that
point you know what it's just cool hand
head is it hair colored hand it's a hair
colored hand in the hair it's kiyah it's
like got like the amount of hair that
like a monkey hand would have it's a
very hairy hand strong too oh yeah you
can hold like you can hold yourself up
but on a pull-up bar with just your head
yes because you'd be like an ornament
you think you'd be using it to
constantly ruffle your hair but with a
hand that's strong you just be hanging
from but you'd be bending over using it
instead of your other two hands well
they marry and if you were going through
like a small space like a tunnel you'd
have your normal hands on the sides and
then the top hand would be like your
head would be your head can hit anything
because it would always be caught by the
head hand oh wow that's a that's good
too and can it does it have a wrist like
can it come down and cover my eyes if
I'm scared mm-hmm is it that big of a
hand
me see no I don't think so I don't think
I can I mean I got a pretty big hand and
I couldn't get your doctor eyes I think
I want to touch your eyes though because
that's when you get pinkeye I think what
I want my hand are you saying that
because I have a sty have you noticed
that no do you see that my right eye is
a little puffy no that's what glasses do
for you man that's why I'm gonna start
wearing glasses in 2019 I went in a row
my eye problems I was in a hot tub over
the weekend and at an air B&B Oh with
some friends and I I was tired and I put
my face under that hot tub and I just
rubbed my face with my hands oh gosh my
two hands and then I came up and I was
like this hot tub smells like lake water
lo and behold I woke up next morning
with a puffy eye was it lake water I
don't know I didn't I didn't do it like
a a test well I know who you were with
and ice he seems like he would have done
a test he didn't seem fazed by it I mean
if they have any skies he didn't test
the water hot compresses I'll be doing
that tonight don't worry about me
and I but if I had a third hand yeah I'm
pretty vain about touching my hair
constantly too so you might be changing
my answer but I also adjust my glasses a
lot if I just had a hand right here
beside my glasses just to constantly
adjust it mm I think I think you that
would work my I think you could use my
hand my answer pinky down there my
answer is I want a hand on the end of a
tail so I don't have a hotel I'm talking
like a monkey tail with a hand on the
end of it you know how you can get those
things that have a sticky border you put
a quarter in that thing at the exit to
the grocery store and you'd get like a
sticky hand like we're talking about
things that are just not opposed but not
sticky I want a hand on a tail I think
that would be great I don't know why but
the hands why we why does he lose hell
man I I just can't believe that
evolutionarily speaking we didn't need a
tail well because we stood up the tail
was for like trees it was for the trees
man we came out of the trees we went on
the savannas we stood up we looked over
the grassland
I would really love to do that tail like
a like just a long expressive tail and I
just for communication also for grabbing
and probably not I think it give me
arranged and have anything can be done a
naughty stuff tail and now you want to
handle the end of it that's definitely
not possible
because it has to be a very easily
controlled tail for the hand to be of
any use
you don't want a tail that is just sort
of hanging there and just wagging you
get that most you can do is wag and then
basically all you're doing is waving all
the time you know what I'm saying you
have to have well it would grab on to
the back of my shoulder so when I was
walking around it but looked like
someone was but I was leading someone by
my shoulder but then I would turn around
and reveal it nope that's just a guy
with a long tail like a four-foot tail
with a with a hand on it enough I think
I'm gonna go with head hand me too okay
we're gonna get into more these
questions but first we're gonna let you
know that you can pick up these mugs the
ear biscuits mug with all new speckle
and this lake water takes great yeah it
holds like water and other beverages I
have on a sweater sweatshirt yeah you do
has a GMM logo on it it's called army
green and armed agree that's pretty
fuzzy
it's very fuzzy that's pretty very very
soft very very warm I I'm in my happy
place and I don't even have a but two
hands your happy place is within March
uh-huh I can relate to that mythical dot
stores where you get all that stuff
let's get into another question Paola
asks Paola isn't that like some kind of
like illegal thing
in another youniverse you guys are
teachers what subject would you like to
teach my answer is pottery like I want
to be a thrower
isn't that what they're called when you
when you're like spinning pottery and
then throw in it you know you it's
called a thrower I have no idea a person
who pots makes pots throws the but you
want to be a teacher you want to be just
the person who makes pots because
there's a distinct difference I actually
don't think it is I want to be a guy who
makes pots and it's like different mud
stuff that's a craftsman so well that I
can teach people but what's more
important it seems like a laughing or
the teaching it seems like it well I
have to be a teacher that's the question
I want to teach it I think it would be
fun to teach you use the teaching
question as a way to get to a hobby that
you want to make into your shut your job
which is fine but I find it interesting
that your the teaching part is not oh
I'll get that what appeals to you I know
I think that it's a teaching as a
concept stresses me out like there's a
lot of pressure associated with like
knowing something so well to then tell
people that stuff and then they're
supposed to believe it and then it
impact their lives like that's but
that's just a lot of pressure like I
don't have that type of confidence in in
knowledge like I always feel like I need
to state everything I counted as an
opinion and you know I'd love to give
opinions
rowrr other things where there aren't
answers but like teaching something
seems so final and like I can I feel
like I can screw up people's lives
unless it's just them making a pot and I
can be very very special to people I
also think be very significant
especially it depends on what you put in
and I like that it's in us it's in a so
in some form I'd like to be an art
teacher where it's not about if if I'm
wrong about something that I've passed
along and somebody's gonna that's
interesting so the reason you went to
art is not because it's because you
value the subjective nature of art
you're afraid to teach anything that
might be
considered to be objective or final in
some way I think that's what drew me to
it and also it seems like I think I
could be of like a Zen teacher of
pottery like I think it could it could
be my class would be equal parts pottery
and therapy like just inspirational like
I want to have an inspirational class
where people are just touching mud mmm
because it's like you're getting in it
it's like it's very primal like you know
playing with mud and dirt and the
spinning motion it could be symbolic of
something that I would make up just to
get people excited I just think there's
a there's a lot of potential it sounds
like you've really thought this through
yeah as you as you know I'm not a
TEDTalk
I mean as you know I make it ted talks
about it I am NOT I'm don't hold back I
don't have a problem with telling people
things yeah in fact well I've talked
about this many times before but you
know my dad's a law professor and he he
he loves teaching not just teaching a
class because he also likes telling you
what he thinks about things in the same
way that I do yeah he likes an audience
if he wasn't a professor he'd be a
stand-up comedian it's like we have a
very similar personality in a lot of
ways and I ended up being the the
comedian not the professor but I'm not I
am NOT making this up I really really
want to be a university professor at
some point in my life and I'm not and
I'm holding out hope that there's gonna
be some opportunity do you think you're
gonna get some like honorary yeah
youtube degree no I don't did to go to
be able to like be like oh I'm gonna
teach this this particular class for
this particular program because of
something that is from my past that
qualifies me to do it in some way I
don't know what it'll be 20 years from
now but so do you have an answer for
what it is
I mean is it law do you want to like no
dad son teach like that would be cool
you're getting in on a now no no
interesting the paycheck well splitting
the duties I'm very wanting with you
there's a lot I'm just interested in so
many different things you have to pick
something walk you're gonna you know
that I like paleontology but I like that
because of the idea of like the clothes
and brushing the dinosaur bones yeah but
you're you're uh you're in a classroom
setting so I don't know I very difficult
for me to just think about it in the
abstract because I'm thinking about
something that I might actually be able
to talk about okay for instance you know
I took that class at NC State from my
favorite class ever the futurism class
and that professor was just an absolute
nut in a few okay that's a good one for
you he had written the textbook oh wow
single space courier font and he put in
his own binder why welcome to the future
I and he wore these red suspenders and
he was kind of hunched over and he had
been teaching a state for many many
years I took I think it's called future
studies and it was like an introduction
to you know my introduction to a lot of
like science fiction writing and Asimov
and stuff like that but I only III
absolutely loved that now I'm no expert
on that but I have an affinity for that
stuff so maybe there's you know there's
something in there post apocalyptic
literature or something that's like this
is just a class that you take when you
know you you got some credits that you
just need to fill up and there's this
guy that used to be on YouTube but yeah
he's the guy with a big white beard
because I'll be old and he's crazy
professor I want to be in like some
college town where on the East Coast
we're like the leaves change and you
walk around with your your sweaters on
that say the mascot and you go to the
basketball games like Division three now
yeah that's your college scene that I'm
talking the future you're teaching the
future to the future that's poetic and
then there's another guy with a white
beard doing pottery to kind of help
people who think visually understand
you're not gonna come to the same school
as me that's me I'm taking half your
paycheck I think you could I think you
might go to the branch a Unity College
just outside of no I love it
I love teaching questionably doing it
Questlove Questlove
see there you go he taught a like a
hip-hop Studies class exactly what I
would I can't really did that but I
would love to have taken that class I'll
be a TA what you want to be a TA for a
celebrity taught class who doesn't yeah
that's the one I will bring my potter's
wheel I'm just not I'm not an another
expert in anything I think that people
would want to pay for it yet so all
right I may another question this is
from praise sharp okay an ask ur of
questions what's the one thing what's
the one thing you thought was super
fancy as a kid but turned out to be an
average not fancy adult thing I thought
Lunchables were fancy in middle school
hashtag ear biscuit I still think
Lunchables are kind of fancy I mean I
kind of cool innovative even still
innovative you to this day still feel
like you're eating future food yeah I
feel like an astronaut yeah astronauts
eligibles fancy a fancy astronaut you
see that video the of the astronaut back
on earth and he's like he's holding up a
cup and he's talking with a pin and then
he lets go of the pin to gesture and
then the pin falls and then he looks up
to try to find a pin this is not a joke
this is not a joke he just like he's
been in space so long that he hadn't
gotten used to when you let something go
it falls gravity I did see that the see
I don't know I saw a video I was on
reddit by the way did you see the video
on reddit where they were teaching the
the guy had been in an International
Space Station for a very long time how
to walk again I didn't I I felt like
that might be too emotional or something
was it funny he didn't have like a
soundtrack no yeah we know it wasn't
funny but it was interesting it was like
dang this guy can't walk anymore it's
probably the same guy who then doesn't
know what to do with a pin you can't
gesture either yeah seriously do ya do
you have something in mind yeah I had a
hard time with this one I don't know
well I think the way I was thinking
about it you'll relate to this
I remember everything seeming fancy like
the whole town have done seem fancy to
me just to you know growing up when we
went to the Chinese restaurant and done
because it had like a gold sign this is
this this was the town you know I'm
saying you drive on 420 110 miles
towards the interstate East and then
you'd get to done with two ends yeah I
had a movie theater with two movies
could play at once
twin plaza yeah probably still got it
now so but but it it went beyond that
cuz it was like shehnai talked about
Shoney's before on the show Shoney's was
super fancy the Mexican restaurant in
Fuquay El Dorado that because you sat
down to eat like oh I never did that all
that you told me you told me about that
oh we're so fancy you told me in grade
school about how you would go to Fuquay
to go to a Mexican restaurant and I was
like what what and I didn't understand
and then once I even in high school I
never ate at the Mexican restaurant I
started getting to know my wife and
started hanging out with her family and
they would like go to like Maggiano's
you know I'm saying we're still in Shane
territory yeah yeah but like that was
like what oh that was the tip top man I
was like I've never eaten in any place
like this in my life and now I'm just
such a douche Darrell no I'm saying
there's that one that I would goats now
I'm just now I'm just a snob now I'm
like well I'm not gonna eat it if it's a
chain you know what I've got it no no
it's got it's got to have four and a
half stars at least it's got to be on
the eater la map and they've got it
right and and and they've got to serve
beats I mean I mean cold beats in a
salad and a lot of sugar and beats watch
that but yeah but growing up man I wish
I could go back to that mentality cuz I
wish I could just turn that on every
single day because then everything would
be amazing
you know what you jog my memory the
thing that I thought was fancy because
you would talk about it that in when you
mentioned done that steak house and done
what was they had a um Heath's yes
Heath's steak house it was like a dimly
lit
room and then you it wasn't like the
Western Sizzlin where I would get a
steak where you'd go through a cafeteria
line in order they would come to your
table and you'd order a steak and then
you would get up after you'd ordered a
steak and you would go to the baked
potato bar
oh man you say potato bar as fancy it's
heath steakhouse film in his Heath
Steakhouse still in Dunn North Carolina
cos how would he know he never even been
to North Carolina he's got the internet
Oh
while he's looking that up what another
fancy thing is and you might know if
it's still there because you've got
family that lives in this town is Ron's
barn still in coats
yes it's called it we remember it used
to be called Pope's barn became Ron
you're still there well it was poked a
long time ago yeah it's not in Ron's for
long it's bumping man it's still
happening that is a if you're in coach
North Carolina is Heath Heath Steakhouse
still there he's still there and done
it's great stars on Yelp and done yeah
you know
how many 20 reviews well you know what
they need more reviews I got to get it
up so go to Heath steakhouse we highly
recommend and if you're in Coates
we also grow up but the go to Ron's barn
the barbecue the chicken I mean you go
you got the trade show so good we also
grew up with a guy named Heath I thought
he was pretty fancy he's the first name
oh yes last night we went we also went
as called he got his Heath yeah that's
right he was his laughing I always
thought that they were the owners of
that place they weren't aiming to do it
they have to Heath Heath to is the name
of the store maybe maybe we only know
about he's one huh how much is it how
much is a ribeye they're gonna get I
just want to get a done North Carolina
ribeye price Oh before you tell me what
get a ribeye Heath to steakhouse and
don't North Carolina
I'll get your number I got my number it
doesn't say okay with that exercise was
going no I know it was $23 oh I was
gonna say 16 oh it ain't that cheap you
don't think so
well we're just going after you only go
home all right got another question for
you
chef's just one two three four down
under asks if you could design a program
physical or digital to make your lives
easier what would it be
yeah I like this question because I like
how things could be easier for me and I
the thing I've been thinking about it I
want a I want my shower to blow-dry my
entire body yeah almost cut yeah doesn't
is that a thing because I should have
gotten that yeah yeah I knew it was
probably oh hold on a second we've
talked about this so they make a thing
that was a Kickstarter we talked about
it on this show we had me sure where it
was a thing that like it looked like a
weight scale but you would get on it and
somehow it would dry your body now Jesse
wanted to get this for me I looked at it
and I was like I just don't see what
works but in the process of looking it
up yeah you can get the showers that not
only have the crazy Jets from all sides
but you can also add in crazy blowers
man a new shower and I didn't even think
about that and now I am I sit there and
I'll get out of the shower and I'll
brush my teeth and then like I break out
the blow-dryer I blow-dry my whole body
and then I look out my window and like
my neighbor can see me well if I don't
close my [ __ ] it's a different problem
um well my neighbor watching me blow-dry
my body I you know what I drove up blah
blah blah armpits I have mixed feelings
about this and my crotch area well yeah
don't let that out I can do that with my
third hand I can have three four blow
dryers going at once as I got four hands
I got one on top of my head well you
blow dry your hair dye handle get hot I
have very mixed feelings about this and
this is coming from a guy who knew about
the nut that it was a possibility that
it was a reality and I am redoing a
bathroom at some time have your float
have you blow-dried your body with a
hair dryer before I have blow-dried my
body with a dryer at an amusement park
were you not there yeah
you were there right yeah well that we
talked about this we got into this into
the stall and you paid like seven bucks
a person think it was that of water park
yeah to get completely dry and at that
point I was like this has got to be
thing now but here's my mixed feelings
my mixed feelings are and again this is
where like stoic philosophy comes in
which i'm i partially subscribed to but
don't really actually you know i read a
book about it and i like the idea of
like denying yourself things so that
just like I was saying a sec ago if I
could go back to that place where
Heath's steakhouse was super exciting to
me then my life would be better because
you thought you were saying then you
wouldn't go no well yeah because this
Stoics had this philosophy that you
should never eat in great food and good
wine you should stay away from that
because you should learn to be
completely sustained off bland food
because you won't become jaded and you
won't be you won't be feeding into this
thing that there's no you you run it up
against the asymptote what you never get
satisfied and I think that putting a
blow-dryer in your shower is an example
of one of those things that will make
you a person that now every time you
have to take a shower
elsewhere like I take a shower the gym
like three times a week they'd have a
blow dryer there and so they do you need
to look for it I know I've pushed every
button there oh all kinds of stuff has
come out but not even in the like when
you go to the sink they don't have a
drawer to blow dryer we have a blow
driver they don't have a blow dryer
built into the shower I know I'm just
saying my idea is good enough okay and
here's the thing about stoicism and blow
dry in your crotch is that if you don't
blow dry your crotch it's eventually
gonna dry so you might as well just
accelerate the process so that no
because the way that the the warm air
feels on your body especially that part
of your body is probably doing it for
pleasure I'm doing it give me a break
you're doing it for pleasure blow-drying
your body is fun and feels great well it
does know exuded
if a stoic saw another stoic blow drying
himself he'd kick him out of the club
right he'd revoke his membership wonder
if my neighbors are stoic
you got another question you know I do
Brian Pearce who would you cast to play
yourselves in the good mythical biopic
which is happening I thought was biopic
until like last year I thought it was
biopic too because we only use that word
with each other neither of you can be in
this movie because thanks for the
clarification because because we suck at
playing ourselves each of you choose an
actor to play yourself and an actor to
play the other guy so I've gotten my
picks Oh for this let me hear it I got
mine too
I'll start with who I think would play
you okay all right you may not know this
guy
logan lerman never heard of this is the
guy who played Percy Jackson in what in
Percy Jackson what is that it's a book
series that was turned into a movie
series you'd recognize this guy I like
it you know just looks like a normal
dude he's got one of those faces
memorable he's got one of those faces
that can be pushing a lot of different
first of all there's a few requirements
and my mom just said push in a lot of
different directions that's what you
just said he has a face that's my third
hand talking a lot of different
directions I think so this is what I
think is required this is got to be
somebody facing can be pushed in a lot
of gosh into their 20s I think the
person has to be in their 20s because
you want to be able to play like you
wanna be able to play like from high
school to like now so that I kind of
think it like a 20 year old something
yeah he's he's in luck he's in talks to
play young Dan Rather in news flash so
hey this guy's yeah this guy's a great
actor and you know what you should
familiarize yourself with him and when
when it the biopic moves into the future
I can be played by Dan Rather exactly so
you should be honored that I picked
honey know about this guy by the way
have you seen Percy Jackson my kids have
seen it okay well no the way that I did
it here let me first of all the way that
I did think of this because I would have
known that that guy's name I looked up
top actors in their 20s and a list came
up top 25 all actors in their top twenty
fives in the top 25 according to this
one public oh okay you're doing me right
so I only pick people who are in the top
25 because for
me as it might seem a little bit of a
stretch literally I picked Daniel
Radcliffe for me and I'm going for who I
think and get to face now Daniel
Radcliffe's about five six I don't I'm
guessing I met in one time so I'm like a
foot taller than him yeah so but he's
very familiar with Hobbit technology and
you know making himself look smaller
than he was so I figured he got the same
thing and make him look bigger
that's a director he's gonna eat the
Milly with Hobbit technology he can play
me well no Peter Jackson is definitely
directing the the one that I'm that were
Dana Radcliffe plays me cuz he's gonna
have to make him look bigger he's got to
make him be the Gandalf what is the
reason why you picked him though because
facial features eyes buggy eyes bring up
a picture of Daniel Radcliffe with his
beard he can play me at different stages
of life so with a beard because I want a
combination if somebody who's a great
talent but also can be me believably
from a physical standpoint I mean the
guy looks like me his his his beard and
hair is lighter than I remembered it
beans but no he has same kind of
eyebrows same facial structure in
general same kind of buggy eyes and now
also I think that Logan has a similar
thing to you like face shape and his let
me look at that look at that second
picture of him go back up that one right
there with a second from the corner
right there no down right there yeah
look on that look at that that you would
think that was me I can make that look
the same person I'm not gonna argue with
you I mean it's just it's not expected
okay but he is too short so again Peter
Jackson we invite you to take the helm
neither one of us were ever gonna say
Daniel Stern and Dana Carvey I mean no
cuz they're old at this point Daniel
Stern in his prime maybe but I mean I'm
yeah I I've want to put a doppelganger I
want to pick a guy who I want to forget
good-looking guy so I can feel good
about the movie you know what I'm saying
I decide his name you know I decided to
go to flip the script you know I think I
think the world is ready for the good
mythical biopic where we where it's it's
the female version mm just like what
they did with ghostbusters right but you
usually have to have the first
before you flip we are the first version
okay that's not how biopic works but I'm
listening
go ahead so I thought just in terms of
personality and physicality I'm picking
I'm picking for me Kristen Bell I think
an interesting I think we got I think we
could be friends I think I think
everyone wants to be Kristen Bell's
friend doesn't everybody want to be my
friend
I'm and I'm a fun guy to have around boy
I'm just locked stocking barrels of fun
so you kind of see yourself as like a
Veronica Mars type yes never seen that
show but yes I mean I'm I'm she's top of
mine because I'm I'm catching up on the
good place okay and then you my friend
would be Jane Lynch she's tall she's
snarky the two of them together would be
a really fun move interesting yeah it's
a really fun money I love it so two
totally allowed to see the two another
good well as all the other stuff she's
done she's got that dry wit and and and
we we know Jane
we know Jane yes she does the the
Epilepsy March right every year so what
we can talk to her about your ID Jane
I've got a pretty good idea we first of
all Kristen Bell is not yet on board
yeah but doesn't just start with wait we
were hoping you'd be the one to talk her
into it yes oh yeah it's um matter of
fact that you just come in and start
hosting our show every is it every month
is it a mother-daughter thing though
because I think that's that one
potential issue there you know they're
not raging congruent they're not really
in the same age range
okay well CGI okay yeah you're right art
you know Peter Jackson's doing it so
right about Peter Jackson taking the old
world war one footage now and basically
applying some crazy technology to it all
to make it look amazing and current to
make it look like it had been restore
stored footage yes
I think it was actually restored to
beyond what it would ever have been
based on the technology at the time you
should look this up just Google Peter
Jackson war footage restoration and I
don't know what that was for but it is
fascinating what is that what is that
for oh it's for a movie is it the biopic
our biopic starring Daniel Radcliffe and
Lucas Lerman Harmon I'm getting bored
let me ask you another question
saw Joe asks if intelligent alien life
exists and it does what is the first
thing you want you would want to know
about their civilization I would want to
know if they have music hashtag ear
biscuits
okay so saw would want to know if they
have music I mean that is that is a
particularly specific question to ask at
first I you know I think it's more of
like once you know your life's not in
danger and they're cool and you're
hanging out and you're just like I don't
know hey let's grab a beer or let's
white illipe but go ahead huh that's
quite a leap to say that they're
friendly well because my answer is I
want to know their weakness tell me your
weakness because I know I don't care how
the initial meeting goes the only way
hmm that the only ending the only
potential ending when two different
species from different parts a lien
species from different parts of the
universe come together the only way it
will end is in the annihilation of one
of the one of the people groups that's
that's just that that's just the rule of
the universe man you have to assume that
that is what's going to happen now we go
in friendly handshakes all that but just
know eventually it's gonna hit the fan
and it's us or them I think you may be
tipping your hand a little bit all four
of them if you ask the question what is
your weakness so
let's try to come up with another way to
get I didn't he didn't see it was a
question it's like what is the first
thing you would want to know about their
civilization I would like what is the
Achilles heel I mean that's the question
I want to know what it is do they have
some thing is there a core in the middle
that we can drop a bomb into that all of
a sudden the whole thing will explode on
itself like the Death Star because if so
I want to know what that is and then
once you find that out your second
question is like hey do you do you have
music music I like the music question I
think it's did y'all have music because
we just blew you up where's the black
box is there music on it
that's a realist man just just to keep
the just the sub thread of this thing of
this fire stoked my answer is gonna be
how do you how do you do too naughty
stuff oh well you want to see a
demonstration yeah give me a
demonstration if you must like I mean
that's the only part of Abbot I remember
how many and it was tentacles or
something right what was it yeah it was
like a tenth a tentacle intertwining of
umbilical nests it didn't seem fun there
was no thrusting come on now now but
yeah I'm I mean and you know what my
question seems innocuous but it could be
the key to finding a weakness and so you
just let me do all the talking once I
get all about Hollywood parties once all
of them tentacle up to each other that's
when we best we kill them all once you
guys all get attached to each other and
start procreating we're going to blow
you up I mean it's right it's real sick
oh hold on there is thrusting he just
brought the video up well that was there
was one thrust in particular it look
like I'm just a vataj coming back you
know about that right he's been working
on that forever
oh gosh yeah there's gonna be four of
them we've got a buddy who lives pretty
close to us who has been travelling all
the way down to Manhattan Beach I think
is where they have been working on it
who's been doing a lot of the costume
costume designing on four but all the
avatars but the funny thing is I was
like what are you working on now is the
well I'm doing you know some not saying
he's not like a stylist I mean literally
is drawing the stuff yeah and this is
like this is his job for like a like a
decade like that's the one way I'm
saying like when she start working on
that we guess just working with him yeah
because he's mean because he's just got
so much stuff what's his name James
Cameron James Cameron the deep-sea diver
that's our friend no no we're good
we got a friend who's working on
advertise same is James Cameron Jim
Cameron yeah we call him Jimmy Jimmy cam
having fun today what is your weakness
James Cameron Jennifer Flores if you
could instantaneously give yourself a
quality you don't already possess
example desire to clean photographic
memory write poetry break dance what
would it be
now keep in mind this is not a
superpower we're not talking about
something that doesn't exist this is
this question matters this is a quality
that humans can have and you could
through a combination of natural talent
and practice get you know straight up
but this is just you can snap your
fingers and you can get it what would it
be instantaneously you know since we're
like working on music and stuff this
isn't my answer but I was thinking like
you're gonna take my answer something in
the music world but I actually I stopped
that because I don't want I didn't want
to go there
okay I I applaud your your efforts in
learning the piano as we gear up for
concerts well and that's what I think
that's what my answer was to be a
virtuoso all on a piano well so on any
instrument because my answer is
different but go ahead it well if it's
an option to be a music musical virtuoso
of all instruments which I mean there
are people who can play a lot of you
but that's kind of multiple skills so I
would definitely do that but if I had to
choose one instrument and this is
probably because I'm just beginning to
learn I do think it would be the piano
yeah because I just think that what you
can explore on the piano is just
limitless I was I was sitting down like
Lando called me over he was like tell me
do you prefer it when I play this song
like this or like this because I'm
encouraged he didn't use the word she
told me I can I can change any way I
want and he played it two different ways
and like I was just so envious and proud
of the way that he was able to move his
fingers on the across the ivories and
he's actually learned to whenever he
feels uh overwhelmed or anxious like he
will go over the piano and start playing
and it will it's a it's a calming a
calming effect does it come out in the
music is he like this is my like angry
song he's not like nothing no it's more
of a calming he always plays like a
calming thing which he's one of the
songs he's working on now but just the
level with which you can get in touch
with it's it's just a connectivity to a
different part of your brain and body
that I'm you know that I am envious of
especially with the piano the way
there's like there's a lot of
physicality with it and it's it's not
it's like a full body experience I mean
are you experiencing that as you're
learning to play the piano and I is it
I'm not used I know it's early well if
the funny thing about this and you will
if you come to the London show or you
come to any of the shows that are booked
for 2019 you will see me play the piano
now interestingly I'm doing it the way
that I've always done which is I didn't
learn any songs I learned a little bit
right easy by Lionel Richie yeah I was
impressed and but then I quickly just
move on to writing my own song and so
what I can do is I can play the songs
that we're going to sing well definitely
gonna sing at least one song I think
hopefully two
and but I am so but I've done this way
with a guitar I was like I didn't I
don't play a bunch of covers on the
guitar right it's just I am able to play
the thing that I'm actually doing and
within the you know the parameters that
this song allows and so then I have to
kind of build and of course I'm starting
out in the key of C because that's the
easiest place to start on the piano and
so you can kind of just get the feel
down before you have to really start
involving involving other parts of the
board that may be intimidating so and
all the instruments I play I can only
play what I play in those songs that we
play them in right I mean you just can't
pick it up and just be like but yeah we
we do the same thing we kind of learn
how to fit like this is what we need to
do for this song right and for for guys
who write musical you know comedy music
right you can kind of get away with that
because I was I went and saw dolls the
more my favorite bands put on an
incredible show at the Orpheum and I was
just like you know sometimes I'm envious
of people who just do the one thing like
I look at the guy playing the piano yeah
and I'm like I'm not saying the guy
doesn't have other interest and other
abilities but he's pretty much what he
does is I'm the guy that plays piano in
this band and he's so good at it and you
know and everybody who plays their own
individual instrument they're just the
whole 10,000 10,000 hours thing they've
just done it and what we tend to do is
just play alright well we're gonna this
is the thing that we're doing let's
figure out how to do that not become
experts but no become good enough at it
to do it and to learn something from it
and then move on to the next thing and I
don't know being able to snap my fingers
and have that ability would just be this
yeah to be a virtuoso instantaneously at
the language that the universal language
that is music right and then you could
just file a music to the aliens which
you Close Encounters of the Third Kind
they communicated via music and now
closing kind of the Third Kind great
movie again they play music and it makes
you cry
yeah it's not realistic because they
play a little song and then it would end
with a laser beam just blowing up the
earth that's that's how it should have
ended hmm unless they were trying to
procreate and then the jokes on them for
me my answer the the one that I'm going
with is I'm just because I'd get so
frustrated with this is that I would be
able to remember everybody's name once
somebody tells me their name I would
just I would know it forever and maybe I
could get away with saying I would
remember everything but I'm just gonna
I'm gonna
this name fright thing I think is
getting worse oh well you're getting
older I'm rain is getting worse
I am psyching myself out there like
people whose names I know I now don't
say their name to their face because I
have this little shred of doubt just
getting bigger and bigger that I'm not
I'm not gonna say their right name well
there's a good reason for that doubt and
I've known him since first grade or
something's gonna be really weird like
Rob Rob just say man I know but that's
it hey man I want you know that's not
that's not a great way to make people
feel valued or known hey yeah hey yeah
hey yeah hey yeah hey girl
okay well hey lady good luck with that
mere eh says what's the best / worst
practical joke but you've played on
someone or that was played on you well
you know the first thing I thought of
the the best / worst practical joke that
we did yeah well we've talked about we
told this story before so I'm gonna tell
an incredibly condensed version and
really what I'm gonna say is that I
learned recently that my kids had never
heard this story we give them a nothing
I mean it's you know even if you've
heard it it's worth hearing again
because it was the best / worst
practical joke we ever played on any
boat but she has excelled both parts
because you have to tell the high-school
part first yeah in high school we were
in a group of friends that was six guys
and six girls there was some dating that
happened off and on you know it was it
was just like a television show
and there was one night in particular
that all the guys were outside and we
were all gonna go someplace together and
the girls were inside one of the girls
houses and we wanted to get inside in
fact link had to do in number two a duty
yeah and I needed to poop and they
thought it would be funny to not let him
in to lock the door so what that turn
thought it would be funny to crap in a
box but like a Tupperware there was
there was a Tupperware box outside and
link went behind the bus her dad drove a
bus her mom her mom drove the Vermont
okay mom drove the bus there was a wood
pile back there too I remember the smell
of wood when I was squatting and mixed
intermingling with the smell of duty
yeah he's trying to poop in the box so
he poops into the Tupperware and then we
take the Tupperware we put it in the
girl's car it was let he was Leslie's
car and it was a white Plymouth a claim
a claim great car puts it under the
front passenger the front seat yeah and
leaves the top off we close the doors
and then we get into our car because the
whole idea was eventually we're all
gonna go someplace in two different cars
or three different cars whatever was I
remember sitting in my car which had we
had the light shined on them as they
were getting in their car her girls come
out of the house and I don't know I
actually wasn't in the car because my
vantage points somehow I was in the
house looking out oh I was in the car I
was in the house I don't know how I got
in there so they get into the car and
then immediately get back out and start
looking at their shoes like who stepped
in dog crap which could happen in North
Carolina and watch it everywhere that's
the moment where it just it felt so good
it felt so successful and the seat to
see them scramble around and look at
everyone to look at their own shoes yeah
now they overreacted it's I'll tell you
it smell worse than any dog poop you
live human human feces is the worst
smell on the planet and mine is the
worst of that so again I mean all I ate
in high school was like Cheetos peanut
butter and chocolate milk so one of the
girls took the Tupperware and went into
Chris Gardner's car
and open the door and threw it on to his
seat through the just straight-up crap
yeah actually I actually wiped that part
from my memory they didn't they didn't
they overreacted they didn't set the
Tupperware down they put it into his
seat great Duke somebody they were angry
now first of all let me I'd let me just
say this is a horrible story don't do
this yes there was something wrong with
us there's still something wrong with us
but you asked the question but at least
I mean we were in high school we were
immature it's not like we were in
college it's not like we were married so
because we were married when we did well
well I'm about to tell which is part two
of this storm no we weren't where are we
yes we were because I remember being in
bed in Chapel Hill with my wife when I
got a call from you-know-who who told us
that we had to apologize we were married
when we did this oh here we are telling
this story again okay so long story
short there was some again some girls
who we knew who were having a party and
they were making a big deal about how
fancy it was going to be and how they
were all gonna dress up like we'll see
about that they were hanging out with
friends I mean I don't think we weren't
even great friends with these girls they
were the guys who were hanging out with
were better friends with that but we
knew everyone involved
so anyway were hanging out with the guys
and we weren't gonna go to the pub we're
gonna go to the party
we're just hanging out over here we were
kind of being holes a little bit already
about the party because we thought that
the fact that they were dressing up and
like give it give yourselves we're all
in college who cares but we started to
tell this old story about the crap in
the car and then I don't know who came
up with the idea but it was why don't we
all start crapping in this Tupperware
and see where that goes and so link went
first Greg went second by the way I
highly recommend you only multi people
if you're gonna crap in a Tupperware go
first I know that Tim harm and Greg
because I didn't I did not I didn't have
to in order to I want to I feel bad
because you know they hate it when we
tell this story yeah right what we did
on the interviews full names and then
we're sitting here telling
again and like every time we do it's
just like all it brings up for most of
them is just like shame and frustration
and like why are we still milking this
common choice 20 years ago I'm sorry
guys we said it I'm sorry we said we was
talking worst we said it was the worst
but we also said it was the best and
we're also still grinning you said it
was the best
I was joking I it's the worst it is
don't recommend this now so the answer
to the question is no everyone didn't
participate but like four guys did
enough I mean all you need is one trust
me
but four is worse than that so then we
came up with a plan it's just so stupid
so so mean don't do this we came up with
a plan to go over to the party I would
begin talking to everybody and create a
distraction in one room and then link
would go in the other room he has a bag
of Lay's potato chips which instead of
the chips in the bag it was a Tupperware
full of human feces he would go he would
put the Tupperware underneath a couch or
some piece of furniture he would take
the top off and then we would all leave
this is exactly what happened we showed
up and within five minutes the plan was
executed we got in the car we gave each
other five like a bunch of idiots and
then we drove back to whoever's house we
were at to begin with and then that was
when the phone started blowing up
because obviously we were the ones that
responsible for it I think it took some
some amount of time for them to actually
locate the yeah not a problem
no seven seven minutes is a long time if
they if it took that long
you just follow your nose really is what
you do and anyway there was quite a
search I was told so we did not respond
to any of the phone calls and then like
I said I did one of the I was married at
the time my wife is still in college I
was still kind of hanging with the folks
in college and which which makes you a
loser anyway right and me because that
was made in another adult much older
than us who knew all of us called me and
was like first of all there was five
guys involved he was like you and Link
need to apologize so we had to be the
ones that go apologize and you know what
I think that was totally fair and so we
went over to
the girl's house we sat down with the
two girls whose house it was
and we apologized and we felt we did
feel bad about it it was a it was a it
was a mean thing to do
but I ended up telling my my kids this
story like a week ago in the past month
and they could not believe that it had
happened so I guess this is the way
people people he doesn't seem that crazy
to me I know it was wrong but they could
not believe that we did it and then it's
heinous when their cousins came into
town the cousins both in high school
my two nephews they were like dad you
got to tell them you got to tell them to
just orinary tale and I told them the
story and again it's just like they're
just like I can't believe that and again
yeah you shouldn't crap in Tupperware
and leave it in places I mean should
have known that but it took two times of
doing it to know that it was wrong but I
thought you told me that they had ideas
for how you could have done the joke
better
well the lock did say dad you should
totally have waited much longer than
right after you've got there like you
should have gone to the party and
they're like an hour into the party
Unleashed it and then stayed for the
search and then been away it wasn't it
wasn't a game of Clue son it was a prank
with we just wanted to leave but if
you're gonna do it you anyway do it that
way it made it painfully obvious how
many miles of toilet paper this is
fitting this is from Michael Albert's
how many miles of toilet paper do you
think you've used hash tag your biscuits
I did the calculation now first of all
oh really did you look at any of my
numbers no you know what happens to me
when I look at numbers well just guess
how many miles of toilet paper do you
think I have used in my life well you
are old yeah and you do wipe a lot yeah
so to the two factors that you need to
know um and a square is about 1/4 inches
yeah traditionally four to four and a
half inches okay in length I went with a
4h measure
oh wow so we're on the same when you're
in the ballpark already uh let's see I'm
gonna say you wanted in kilometers or
miles I would like it in miles because
that is what Michael asked for okay
um blood mime on Twitter I'm gonna I'm
gonna say just for nice for a nice clean
answer a marathon 26 miles okay that is
not a bad guess at all because I
calculated 38 miles well 38 miles know
so I understand it what I based this on
is me over the course of a lifetime
averaging 20 squares per wipe for Tripp
that's first of all that's too much
that's too that's the proper adjustments
you were reckless in this yeah so I use
less than that now I use a minimal
amount of squares at this point but it
doesn't take long to get to 20 squares
now that came out to an average of twice
two craps a day two craps a day an on
average okay I would say one I think
ones pointy like 200 and 1,000 feet
basically which comes out to 38 miles
which is about a mile of toilet paper a
year now just to make sure that I wasn't
crazy I did go on the Internet's and I
did look up that the average person
according to Mental Floss does about 1.3
miles per year so I was I was in my
calculation was in the ballpark and what
this equates to is about 50 pounds of
toilet paper per person per year which
this is surprising to a two-person
household goes through on average one
tree worth of toilet paper per year a
two-person household a two-person
household doing that I wipe a tree's
worth 1.3 miles of toilet paper per year
which is about 50 pounds of toilet paper
equates to a tree you know I don't know
how big a tree a tree is it could be
yeah
you yeah that's quite a sliding scale on
the size of trees but a tree's worth of
toilet paper just think about that next
time you're cleaning up you surprise it
there's not some other you know some
some some chamois version of a paper
towel I
that's the reuse no doubt there is I'm
sure you read only Amazon and like a
reusable just remember we met that guy
in Asheville North Carolina when we were
shooting the pilot episode for
commercial Kings his name was like star
or something like that you know he's one
of those older hippie dudes that was
essentially homeless in that in
Asheville uh-huh but he had created one
single like plastic bags worth of trash
for the entire year he was like this is
all the waste that I have created for
the year he always so what did he wipe
his butt with whatever your chamois
you're talking about oh he had a chamois
no doubt now because it's just like the
cloth diapers yeah this is like gonna
happen use a bidet yep even after the
well if you have a bidet with a blow
dryer but that you really got a stay
down there for a while to get completely
dry yep yep doesn't happen so well
that's it we're ending with some math
we've saved enough time since we're
since we're you know we're at this point
in the podcast I wanted to get into a
recommendation because you said we're
gonna end the podcast with a
recommendation right so the recs are in
effect check baby check baby 1 2 3 4 so
each week one of us will have one
recommendation sometimes we will both
have a point of reference for this
sometimes we won't this one is a dual
rec yeah so this is something that my
kids found I was and then you texted it
to me and it blew my mind
I was with my boys over the holidays and
we were the three of us were in the hot
and we started watching YouTube videos
and they were like Dada Dada Dada Dada
Dada Dada did search badlands chugs
Badlands space chugs see Hey Jude yes I
was like Badlands Chuck they were like
we love this guy we love him mm-hmm
so Badlands chugs is the recommendation
for this week this is you sent me a link
to a particular episode that was it was
like it was a tutorial there was the
tutorial part one tutorial part one this
is the first thing I ever watched and I
you know I had a great experience
starting with that particular video you
don't have to start there but I feel
like you get the full breadth of what
Badlands is about if you watch the
tutorial yeah I mean he's a mountain of
a man who it I started looking on
Wikipedia and finding out who this guy
was just the backstory is he's a
professional competitive eater yeah but
he also is a professional chugger of
liquids and then he has youtube videos
where he's just chugging different
things and it's remarkable it's
remarkable and but then he does a
tutorial in in multiple parts where he
teaches you his techniques he calls it
opening up the chug books but the way
that he talks the things he chooses to
say in the ways that he chooses to
insert like pregnant pauses because
there's not much if any edit well that's
it it's brilliant I think that's the
most significant thing beyond everything
that you just said is the fact that at
least in the 10 or so videos that I've
watched no jump cuts and he doesn't no
pun intended
milk it so you've got he has by the way
chugged an entire gallon of chocolate
milk and he does it in one single Chuck
okay in like under a minute it's nuts
now I don't know if he throws up later
but he doesn't show you that but so many
so many youtubers and we may be guilty
of this to some degree but we don't
really make these kinds of videos but
you know I watch I'll click on those
videos where the
you know there's dudes in Australia who
like drop things they go out and drop
things off of that Tower
I haven't seen it they got they
somewhere in the Western like near Perth
or something in the western part of
Australia and entertaining videos I
can't remember the name of them but they
they drop things on to things it sounds
like something that we would do it seems
that that's the main thing they do at
least those are the ones that I've
clicked on and but they they're really
playing the YouTube game hard we know
about that the videos are over ten
minutes long they are there's a bunch of
editing and they're constantly kind of
building up to something they're asking
you to subscribe and to hit like and the
different things and playing the YouTube
game all throughout which I can tolerate
it because I understand that that's how
you got to make a living
Badlands Chuck says uh-huh what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to cut the camera
on I'm going to tell you what I'm doing
I'm going to show you the sprite
cranberry that I'm about to chug there's
gonna be a very short intro that says
badlands chugs or something like that
and then it's gonna come back and I'm
gonna chug this thing and then when I'm
done I'm gonna say see you next time and
it's gonna be as long as it is which is
typically two minutes or less and that's
a badlands chugs video that's what
opened up the chug books is all about I
like at the end of like tutorial part
one it was like and next time I'll teach
you something else it's like he doesn't
you can tell he doesn't quite know what
he's gonna teach you neck just like
he'll figure it out before before there
and then he does it he teaches it to you
so that's the recommendation if you've
got some time to kill badlands chugs I
mean you want time to kill you need to
rearrange your life you want to see
prioritize a man just absolutely kill
beverages ah I'd love to meet him I
think I think he was on Kimmel a few
years back so it's not like we're the
first to discover this guy oh no no no
he's he's he's a he recently passed he's
dead no you're easily passed 200
[Laughter]
I think he's zeroing in on 200,000
subscribers hopefully well we'll send
him over the edge maybe we can get him
on maybe we can get him on our show
I'd love to Chuck man love to chug with
that man let's look into that all right
thanks for hanging with us and listening
to us answer questions that other people
have asked on the Internet
that's what just happened hmm
people asked like that and we answered
them we just you know from our own
personal experience and knowledge and
hmm he got it's real I mean it was break
out real I really like the spin you put
on that yeah thank all right hit that
like button click the bell all that
Jezebel for notifications make sure you
like comment and subscribe and we're
gonna be dropping a bowling ball onto a
block of ice from 100 feet at the end of
this video you know we would if they had
already done it we don't have a tower
like that and come back next week and
we'll teach you something else you can't
do that in Los Angeles
hashtag air biscuits talk at us and then
next week we'll talk back at you to
watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]